FIRST.
THAT'S A PRETTY BIG PREDICTION
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
OBVIOUSLY HE WANTS TO REMAIN
HOPEFUL AND OPTIMISTIC IN ALL OF
THIS.
IN TERMS OF STRATEGY, AL, THE
PRESIDENT USED A PRIMETIME
ADDRESS A FEW DAYS AGO THIS WEEK
TO TALK ABOUT THREATS TO
DEMOCRACY.
POLL AFTER POLL SHOWS THE
ECONOMY IS THE ISSUE.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE CHOICE FACING
VOTERS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IT'S BOTH.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT THE EXAMINE IS WHAT'S ON
PEOPLE'S MIND.
INFLATION.
YOU KNOW, REPUBLICANS HAVE
REALLY THE ONLY SPENDING THAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT CUTTING IS
SPENDING THAT HELPS PEOPLE.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT CUTTING
MEDICARE, ABOUT OVERTURNING
PROVISIONS OF THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT, MEDICARE BEING
ABE TO NEGOTIATE WITH
PHARMACEUTICALS THAT EVERY OTHER
DEVELOPED COUNTRY DOES THAT.
WE SPEND TWO TO THREE TIMES AS
MUCH AS AS THEY DO.
THEY WANT TO REPEAL THAT.
THAT IS PART OF THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT.
$35 INSULIN FOR SENIORS.
THEY WANT TO REPEAL THAT.
THAT WILL JUST HURT PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE -- OTHER THAN THAT, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
ABOUT INFLATION.
I HAVEN'T HEARD.
THEY JUST TALK THAT GAME.
SO I THINK ECONOMICS ARE
IMPORTANT.
THEY HAVE TO BE.
AND THEY OF COURSE ALSO WILL
WANT TO CUT TAXES ON PEOPLE,
UPPER INCOME PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ALWAYS WANT TO
DO.
AND THAT BEGIN WILL TAKE THAT
AWAY.
YOU SEE RON JOHNSON HAS TALKED
ABOUT VOTING ON MEDICARE AND
SOCIAL SECURITY EVERY YEAR.
RICK SCOTT, WHO HEADED UP THE
SENATE CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE FOR
THE REPUBLICANS HAS TALKED ABOUT
THAT.
HAS TO COME UP FOR RENEWAL EVERY
FIVE YEARS.
THIS SHOULD BE VERY, VERY
ALARMING.
AND, LOOK, I WON MY FIRST TERM
IN THE SENATE -- I WON BY 312
VOTES.
EVERY VOTE COUNTS.
SO MY MESSAGE TO DEMOCRATS IS
GET OUT THERE, VOTE, AND DOOR
KNOCK IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO IN MINNESOTA.
WE GET OUT THE VOTE AND WE KNOCK
ON DOORS.
STKPEUPT YOUR VIEWERS TO DO
THAT.
>> AND, CHARLIE, LET ME ASK YOU
THIS, WE JUST HEARD FROM PHIL
MATTINGLY A FEW MOMENTS AGO.
HE TOUCHED ON THIS.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE PENNSYLVANIA
RACE.
TONIGHT HE'S GOING TO CAMPAIGN
WITH FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP,
MEHMET OZ.
AS WE KNOW HE'S TALKING ABOUT
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN A FEW
WEEKS, ACCORDING TO HIS AIDES.
TRUMP HAS MAJOR COMPETITION.
OPRAH WINFREY WHO HELPED MAKE OZ
A STAR, IS ENDORSING JOHN
FETTERMAN.
DO YOU THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO
APPEAR WITH HIM AT THIS STAGE OF
THE RACE?
THERE ARE FOLKS WHO ARE STRAIGHT
DOWN THE MIDDLE IN FIRMS OF
THEIR POLITICS.
COULD THIS BE A LAST-MINUTE
TURNOFF?
>> WELL -- CAMPAIGN I WOULD HAVE
ADVISED AGAINST.
RIGHT NOW OZ NEEDS TO WIN SWING
VOTERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOESN'T DO A LOT
TO HELP HIM THERE.
SO I WOULD BE AGAINST IT.
I KNOW JOE BIDEN AND BARACK
OBAMA TODAY AS WELL.
I DON'T THINK THE SURROGATES
WILL MAKE MUCH OF A DIFFERENT.
HE WAS CLOBBERED IN THE
MIDTERMS.
HE HAD A POOR PERFORMANCE IN
2014.
JOE BIDEN IS UNDER WATER.
THE SENATE RACE WILL BE
DECIDED -- IT'S VERY TIGHT RIGHT
NOW.
AND I THINK IT'S DEAD EVEN, TO
BE QUITE HONEST.
IT IS AN ADVANTAGE TO OZ.
AFTER THE DEBATE THAT WAS
DISQUALIFYING FOR FETTERMAN,
THINGS HAVE REALLY MOVED.
AND PARTICULARLY AMONG COLLEGE
EDUCATED MEN ARE MOVING OZ AWAY
FROM FETTERMAN LARGELY AFTER
THAT DEBATE PERFORMANCE.
THE CRIME ISSUE IS EFFECTIVE,
CONTRASTING THE VOTES BETWEEN
FETTERMAN AND SHAPIRO.
AND THAT IS REALLY HAVING AN
IMPACT.
OF COURSE IN THE ECONOMY AND
INFLATION THEY ARE REALLY THE
PRIMARY ISSUE.
NO ONE SHOULD UNDERSTATEMENT
THAT.
AND FETTERMAN MADE A MISTAKE
WHERE HE COULDN'T ARTICULATE HIS
VIEW ON FRACKING.
AND IN PENNSYLVANIA MAJOR
ECONOMIC ISSUE, ENERGY ISSUE,
PEOPLE FOLLOW IT CLOSELY.
I THINK RIGHT NOW OZ IS VERY
WELL POSITIONED TO WIN THE
SENATE RACE, AS IS SHAPIRO THE
GUBERNATORIAL RACE.
>> AL, YOU WANT TO CHIME IN
THERE?
>> YEAH.
OZ MADE A MISTAKE IN THE DEBATE
TOO, WHICH HE SAID THAT A
WOMAN'S CHOICE TO HAVE AN
ABORTION SHOULD BE BETWEEN HER
DOCTOR, HERSELF, AND HER LOCAL
POLITICAL OFFICIAL.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S --
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
YEAH.
AND I ALSO -- THAT ENABLED
DEMOCRATS TO RUN ADS LINKING HIM
TO MASTRIANO.
THAT IS A TACTICAL MISTAKE.
BECAUSE HE IS AGAINST ANY
ABORTION EVEN FOR THE LIVE OF
THE MOTHER AND RAPE.
SO I THINK THAT WAS A VERY BIG
MISTAKE.
I HAVE SEEN THE POLLS, TOO,
CHARLIE.
FIRST OF ALL, POLLS, THEY
TIGHTENED.
BUT FROM WHAT I'VE SEEN,
FETTERMAN IS STILL AHEAD I THINK
IN MOST OF THEM.
MAYBE I HAVEN'T SEEN THE LATEST
POLLS.
IN THE LAST DAY OR SO.
IT'S GOING TO BE A TIGHT RACE.
WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE IS SO MUCH.
IT'S NOT JUST DEMOCRACY.
IT IS CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT IS MAJOR EQUALITY.
IT IS ROE.
THERE IS SO MUCH AT STAKE HERE.
AND OZ IS ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
THESE.
>> LET ME SAY ONE THING ABOUT
THE DEBATE.
THE ISSUE, YES, DID HE STUMBLE
ON THE ABORTION QUESTION?
NO DOUBT.
THE PROBLEM FOR FETTERMAN, MANY
PEOPLE WATCHED THAT DEBATE AND
QUESTIONED HIS CAPACITY TO SERVE
IN OFFICE.
BECAUSE THE FETTERMAN CAMPAIGN
HAS BEEN -- THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
TRANSPARENT.
THEY UNDERSTATED THE HEALTH
ISSUE.
THEY SHOULD HAVE REPLACED HIM
BACK IN THE SUMMER WHEN THEY HAD
THE CHANCE.
IT WAS APPALLING AND SAD THEY
PUT HIM OUT THERE UNDER THOSE
CONDITIONS.
MANY PEOPLE WATCH THAT AND THEY
DON'T THINK HE IS ABLE TO DO THE
JOB, NOTWITHSTANDING WHATEVER
MISTAKES HE MADE.
THOUGH HE WAS CRISP AND CLEAR IN
HIS ANSWERS.
AND FETTERMAN WAS NOT.
THAT IS WHAT IS DRIVING A LOT OF
THE ELECTION.
THE AVERAGE HAS OZ UP .1%.
SO IT'S DEAD EVEN.
THIS CAN GO ANY WAY.
AND I THINK OZ IS TRYING TO KEEP
DISTANCE FROM MASTRIANO.
HE IS A DISASTER FOR REPUBLICANS
FOR A WHOLE HOST OF REASONS I
DON'T NEED TO GET INTO.
I THINK OZ IS POSITIONED TO WIN.
>> I WANT TO GET TO WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN LEARNING THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS, HE IS EYES AN ANNOUNCEMENT
IN LESS THAN TWO WEEKS.
HERE HE WAS TEASING THE CROWD
ABOUT THIS THIS WEEK.
>> IN ORDER TO MAKE OUR COUNTRY
SUCCESSFUL AND SAFE AND
GLORIOUS, I WILL VERY, VERY,
VERY PROBABLY DO IT AGAIN.
OKAY.
THERE YOU GO.
VERY PROBABLY.
>> GET READY.
.
THAT'S ALL I'M TELLING YOU.
VERY SOON.
GET READY.
>> AL, I JUST WONDER, SHOULD
THIS BE A MOTIVATING FACTOR FOR
DEMOCRATS ON TUESDAY?
THE REPUBLICANS WERE ALL BUT
BEGGING TRUMP TO PLEASE STAY ON
THE SIDELINES, PLEASE DON'T MAKE
AN ANNOUNCEMENT BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS.
BUT TO SAY EARLY NOVEMBER, LATE
NOVEMBER, WE WILL ANNOUNCE WE'RE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
ISN'T THIS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO REMIND VOTERS, GUESS WHO
IS COMING BACK.
GUESS WHO IS TRYING TO GET BACK
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> IT IS NOT ONLY A MOTIVATING
FACTOR FOR DEMOCRATS BUT FOR
CHARLIE AND THOSE WHO SEE WHO HE
IS, A SOCIOPATH.
YOU KNOW, AND I ALSO AGREE WITH
CHARLIE.
MAYBE IT WASN'T CHARLIE WHO SAID
IT, TRUMP IS IN THERE FOR
HIMSELF.
HE ISN'T THERE TO HELP OZ.
HE IS THERE FOR HIMSELF.
AND I THINK THAT WILL BACKFIRE,
AND I HOPE IT WILL BACKFIRE.
OF COURSE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, CHARLIE?
DO YOU WISH DONALD TRUMP WOULD
HAVE STAYED OUT OF THIS ALL THE
WAY UNTIL AFTER THE MIDTERMS?
IT'S ALMOST LIKE HE CAN'T HELP
HIMSELF.
>> HE SHOULD NOT SHOW UP IN ANY
SWING STATE.
HE SHOULD NOT BE IN GEORGIA, HE
SHOULD NOT BE IN PENNSYLVANIA,
HE SHOULD NOT BE IN WISCONSIN.
MAYBE OHIO.
OKAY.
I GET THAT.
HE IS IN MAR-A-LAGO.
THE POINT I'M MAKING IS THIS IS
A DISASTER.
RIGHT NOW THIS IS ALL ABOUT
GETTING THOSE SWING VOTERS.
YES YOU WANT TO SPIKE UP YOUR
BASE A BIT.
THE ONLY GOOD THING HE IS NOT IN
THE PHILADELPHIA MEDIA MARKET IF
YOU'RE MEHMET OZ.
AND THAT IS THE ONLY GOOD THING.
SHAOE NOT BE HERE BECAUSE ALL
THIS DOES IS REMIND PEOPLE,
HOPEFULLY ENTER CONVENIENCE.
HE'S DONE IT IN THE PRIMARY
HELPING TO NOMINATE SOME
CHALLENGING CANDIDATES OR EXOTIC
CANDIDATES TO BE POLITE.
AND HE'S REALLY COMPLICATED THIS
ELECTION CYCLE FOR REPUBLICANS
WHEN THEY SHOULD BE WALKING AWAY
WITH THIS MIDTERM RIGHT NOW.
EVEN THOUGH THE ROE DECISION HAS
GIVEN DEMOCRATS SOME ENERGY.
TRUMP IS NOT HELPING.
AND IF HE ANNOUNCES AFTER THE
ELECTION AND THERE IS A RUNOFF
IN GEORGIA, IT COULD BE A REPE